smiling preacher joel osteen the senior
pastor of america's largest congregation
has come under fire for reportedly
closing his doors to victims of the
houston floods we'll analyze on this
prosperity podcast your best car ride
now plus we'll have partes Sayla and
kelly Campania join the panel of
deplorable x' to discuss hillary clinton
live god help us
north korea's latest act of war and the
health benefit benefits of coffee and
coffe fa i'm michael Knowles this is the
Michael Dahl show
[Music]
talk about the power of positive
thinking we're here today in the Ben
Shapiro studio we have taken over maybe
this prosperity stuff really works it is
about a hundred and fifty five million
degrees outside right now which is the
one day or one of two days of the year
in the valley of Los Angeles that
they've decided to fix our air
conditioning units so we're all in this
bunker we're all broadcasting out of
Ben's today and we're just gonna be
sweating bullets for you all that's the
kind of charity that we do here so we
have to talk about Joel Osteen Joel
Osteen is this preacher he's that guy
who's always smiling you see him on TV
he's lumped in with the prosperity
gospel big televangelist he actually has
the largest congregation in the country
that's 52,000 weekly attendees he's
gotten very rich doing it he has made I
think his net worth is about 40 million
dollars he lives in a ten and a half
million dollar house and so anyway he
was accused of closing off the doors to
his Houston Church which houses could
seat 16,000 during this flood initially
there was some confusion the spokesman
said that the property was inaccessible
quote because of surrounding waters and
then he went on and said it makes no
sense to open Church doors when the city
and county already have places for the
victims to go where their medical
facility isn't food and so on now this
was contradicted by some people on
social media who drove by the church and
noticed that there didn't seem to be any
floods on the streets or in the parking
lots then some members of the church
came in and said really there are a lot
of floods in certain parts of the area
so it's a little confusing Osteen has
firmly denied that they closed the doors
he said we have never closed our doors
even though people it appears didn't go
in there for for a refuge or for housing
so hard to believe that claim exactly a
quote we will continue to be a
distribution center for those in need
we're prepared to house people once the
shelter's reach capacity Lakewood Church
will be a value to the community in the
aftermath of this storm in helping our
fellow citizens get on with their lives
now for those who haven't been awake at
3:00 in the morning and watched Joel
Osteen preaching on TV here is just a
short
to give you a sense of his breaching
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fair that it's not fair it was actually
not joel osteen that was Cartman but I
just loved that clip of preacher Cartman
not totally fair but it does give you a
little sense of the spectacle that Joel
Osteen puts on and finally we got our
producer marshal saved that's a pretty
good benefit let's go to a clip of Joel
Osteen actually preaching we love you if
you're ever in our area I hope you'll
stop behind be a part of one of our
services promise you will make you feel
right at home but thanks so much for
tuning in today thanks again for coming
out I'd like to start each week with
something funny and I heard about this
man he was walking up to a country store
and there was a little boy sitting on
the front porch with a huge dog sitting
next to him the man said son does your
dog bite he said no sir my dog doesn't
bite men reach down to pet the dog and
the dog took about half of his arm off
he pulled it back it said son I thought
you said your dog didn't bite the little
boy said that's not my dog now this clip
reminded me of something that my priest
did I talked about often George rattler
my priest in New York said which is that
those those preachers who tell jokes
like a ham actor and a dying vaudeville
show should limit their repertoire to
those jokes that st. John told the
Blessed Virgin while her son bled on the
cross which is a different preaching
style you might tell Joel Osteen a
little bit lighter a little lighter on
theology in particular and the message
he's preaching is all about being
positive let's go he really zeros in on
exactly what he's talking about your
clip of what the thesis of Joel Osteen
sermons is you may not realize it but
you entered a guilt-free zone you might
as well leave it
side this is a righteous place is a
guilt-free zone we shouldn't this is
very different than my own liturgical
experiences as a Catholic where we
strike our breasts and say my fault my
fault my grievous fault it's all about
you know building up self-esteem he's
written a lot of books to this idea and
this may be in part why he attracts
fifty thousand people a week to his
church here is Osteen describing this to
Chris Wallace the voice inside yourself
and making sure that your inner
conversation is positive I was really
struck by that explain what that means
yeah I think it's it's a problem that a
lot of people have and it keeps them
back it holds them back in life and it's
a I believe in our subconscious or in
our thinking that we have a conversation
going with ourselves or I call it a
recording play and a lot of people the
recording is negative you know I have
friends they'll preach a great sermon
and they'll drive home sick if I didn't
do good today and if I just known it a
little bit better but I try to teach
people that I believe God wants us to be
positive - what ourselves meaning that
you know what I like the way I look I
like the way I sound I'm happy with what
I'm doing in my career and not always be
beating ourselves down I think that's
just you know I see people they won't be
negative toward other people but inside
they're negative toward themselves and I
think that holds us back now it's really
hard not to like this guy some people
describe him as Tony Robbins who
occasionally talks about God he is just
this very positive nice obviously very
talented speaker articulate and so that
this is what he's preaching his
positivity whether or not it was a fair
attack it's unclear some tweets said
that it you know he did close the doors
to his neighbor's some tweet said that
he did not close the doors to his
neighbor's it's really not sure nor does
it really matter they're doing a great
job at the recovery efforts in Houston
anyway the more interesting thing is
this theology is this movement that is
so in many ways American this prosperity
theology and for a reference of this
Joel Osteen sent out one tweet that's
gotten quite popular which said quote
don't waste time with people who don't
appreciate what you have to offer the
people around you should celebrate who
you are
and this presents an obvious problem
because the center of the religion that
joel osteen is ostensibly preaching was
a guy who spent a lot of time with
people who didn't appreciate him they so
didn't appreciate him that they nailed
him to a cross and killed him and then
three days later he came back from the
dead so there is a little bit of a
problem in this theology and some people
are angrier at him than others a lot of
people call him a heretic and someone
preach a false prophet and you see these
sort of things I'm not sure that that's
quite fair because I don't know that
he's ever called himself a true prophet
the question is what what does
prosperity mean the this prosperity
theology that he preaches has roots back
in the 19th century goes back to a guy
named Oral Roberts who is a minister
Joel Osteen attended Oral Roberts
University and he basically said expect
material expect a material prosperity
trust in God and good things are gonna
happen to you it comes from a mixture of
Pentecostalism the new thought which was
a movement also in the 19th century
comes from the the unpublished writings
of Phineas Quimby and it's basically the
power of positive thinking and the
gospel of wealth which is Andrew
Carnegie's theory of philanthropy that
when wealth disparity became immense in
the United States during that time it
was incumbent upon the rich to help the
poor in a way that would actually
benefit them and not encourage the
promulgation of Vice or something to
that effect now there is some biblical
warrant to this point of view that if
you trust in God and you have faith and
you know you do your best and God will
do the rest that you'll have a good
material life we see this especially in
Deuteronomy if you follow God's commands
you will prosper if you don't then you
won't we see it in Psalms Psalms is
constantly talking about following God's
will and and it will bring you good good
returns and Christ says this too and in
the New Testament we have Sikhi the
kingdom first the kingdom of God the
rest will be given unto you the birds of
the air and the flowers of the field are
dressed very well and they don't do
anything how much more will our
take care of you and much more will your
Father in heaven take care of you and so
there there is a scriptural basis for a
lot of what he's saying and it seems
unfair to criticize him as being totally
outside of Scripture the trouble is
there a lot of scriptures that also
don't talk about this and it's hard to
talk to someone in the third world
or someone who's suffering from a
terminal illness and say well just have
better faith and more good things will
happen to you that seems shallow and
unlikely because the scripture also
includes job job is a good guy he does
everything God asks him to do and
because God makes a bet with the devil
just the worst imaginable things befall
him he loses his family he loses as well
he loses his health everything is taken
away from him you know it's not so much
that what Joel Osteen says is wrong it's
that he leaves that a lot of things that
are right so you notice on his altar on
his stage there's no cross and one
reason given for that is that he doesn't
want to alienate people who would find
the cross offensive or off-putting and
there's no serious accounting for
suffering suffering is always a test you
know in his account of things and that
doesn't seem to be the case throughout
our experience of humanity and and in
Orthodox Christianity so you know the
rain falls on the just and the unjust
alike Aquinas has asked this why do
wicked men prosper and you know what
what do we really mean by prosperity if
you read Joel Osteen and think of
prosperity as a spiritual prosperity and
the joy that comes from faith then he's
absolutely right then what he's saying
is absolutely true if you read it and it
means you make 40 million dollars and
you have a very nice house and in
Houston I don't know that that's exactly
theologically sound you know Osteen also
talks about charity a lot and he's ding
for this here here's him on Larry King
talking about his work stream of charity
we've had ministers on who said your
record don't count you either believe in
Christ they don't if you believe in
Christ you are you are going to heaven
if you don't no matter what you've done
and you have you wait yeah it's there's
probably a balance between I believe you
have to know Christ but I think that if
you know Christ if you were believer in
God you're gonna have some good works
and I think it's a cop-out to say well
I'm not Christian but I don't ever do
anything to hell with a few Jewish or
Muslim and you don't accept Christ at
all you know I just I'm very careful
about saying who and would and wouldn't
go to heaven I don't know I think I
believe I believe they're wrong I don't
know if I believe they're wrong I
believe here's what the Bible teaches
and from the Christian faith this is
what I believe but I just think that
only god can judge a person's heart and
all just in here you have to give it to
him is quite honest he this is
theologically sound James says faith
without works is dead Christ says
whoever does the will of my father is my
brother and my sister and my mother and
now what one issue here is Osteen says
well only god can judge nobody has the
keys to the kingdom of heaven but we
know that isn't true we know that Christ
tells Peter Peter you're your now Simon
you are Peter and on this rock I will
build my church here are the keys to the
kingdom of heaven whatever you bind on
earth will be bound in heaven whatever
you loose on earth will be loosed in
heaven and there's a real honesty in
Osteen saying that guy isn't me I do not
have the keys to the kingdom of heaven
I'm not going to condemn people and I'm
not going to tell tell you who is going
to heaven and his reluctance to talk
about that is seen as cowardice I think
in a lot of quarters in Christianity and
on the right but at least he's honest
he's not overstepping his bounds one
issue is he always talks about how good
we are build up self esteem but let's
not forget Jesus says in the scripture
why call us thou me good there is none
good but me but one that is God but if
that wilt enter into life keep the
commandments
so now we're talking about Joel Osteen's
charity and were brought up against this
one big act his moment to shine this
once-in-a-lifetime natural disaster hits
his home town and it appears that he did
not handle this very well whether he
really locked the doors or not clearly
he was not opening this monster church
to invite the people of his neighborhood
and this is gonna fuel his critics this
is going to fuel people who say he's
only in it for the money I'm not
accusing him of that I'm not certain of
it I always seemed a lot better than
some of the other prosperity preachers
and televangelists to me but it's a real
more
against him and he's gonna have to
answer for that you know he is primarily
a televangelist and an author all of his
books have basically the same title
become a better you your best life now
it's your time think better live better
and he's really he's honest about what
he does and what he doesn't do hears him
also on Fox News Sunday you know as a
pastor I'm not trying to get everybody
to that's not my main calling like Billy
Graham's he was in evangelist he went
out trying to win everybody to Christ
and I am ultimately trying to do that
but I'm trying to teach people how to
live their everyday lives and so I do
focus on it probably not as much as some
people would like he admits he's not an
evangelist in the traditional sense he's
very straightforward about that I took a
look at his Twitter feed he has a Joel
Osteen has tweeted sixteen thousand one
hundred times he's used to the words
Jesus or Christ one hundred and twelve
times which is a fairly small percentage
of all of his tweets now the guy is
honest about what he is we're seeing his
true colors probably in this storm and
that would be just fine except that he
is the senior pastor of the largest
church in America so now we need to
bring on our all-female panel of
deplorable --zz and we have two new
guests today we have Kelly Campania and
partes Sayla who is written for the
daily wire before and now is writing for
lots of other people Kelly you are no
stranger to that old-time religion is
there any room in this world for the
prosperity gospel
well my I'm gonna step back for a minute
and put the question to his side
aside I think that the problem with Joel
Olsteen
not opening his church is more so a
liability question because my my dad was
actually a pastor for ten years and we
had a school actually come to and they
had some problems with their boiler and
blew up or something and they wanted to
use our building which was right across
the street and they said can we do that
and my dad said okay but then he
actually had to increase the insurance
just on the building just so that they
could use the church or the church
building for three weeks or whatever it
was for the Christian school across the
street so I shocking me and up and
defending Joel Steen on this may be
other liability reasons why he can't
open the doors that are not being talked
about because churches have to bend over
backwards just to keep their own
property I went to a church in the San
Francisco Bay Area that they were
requiring all kinds of expensive change
it's just that they could keep the
building and then they were told
afterwards oh yeah you're gonna have to
fix may revert the building back to its
original status when you leave so there
that's kind of beside the whole
prosperity gospel thing I felt that - I
agreed that you know I often judge a man
by his critics and the people who were
pouncing on Osteen didn't seem to me
people who thought he wasn't Christian
enough it was people who were pouncing
on him because he purports to be a
Christian and there is this obvious
liability issue there are what seemed to
be plenty of housing facilities for
these victims already in Houston so if
they don't need to open up the this
space which doesn't have adequate
doctors and perhaps food and so on and
so forth then why do it I felt it was a
little bit of a disingenuous attack on
him though there are plenty of the
reasons to discuss the issues with his
what he does just on the point of the
prosperity gospel I noticed with Joel
Olsteen that there's never any biblical
references there's never any citations
of verses so and that's kind of for me I
can't take somebody seriously if they
don't actually know the Bible and
they're trying to tell me how to live my
life through what I should shouldn't be
doing I'm growing up with these types of
people all my life and I'm repulsed by a
lot of what they do it's I mean he's not
you know what you gotta think better
about yourself this is a guilt-free zone
um Romans put 3:23 for all have sinned
and fall short of the glory of God we
forget about that first there I mean
Jesus died to make you wealthy yeah and
he was thinking that when he meant that
when he had nails in his hands and feet
that's exactly what he was thinking
about right there man there was it was
quite a defense of Joel Osteen that
really took a turn well on that point
dear viewers we have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube thank you to all
the current subscribers who can go over
right now to daily wire.com we really
appreciate it because normally we're
able to take
those subscriptions and have studios
with air-conditioning except for today
today we're in this bunker and that's
totally fine if you go over there right
now it is $10 a month $100 a year you
get me you get the inter Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show but forget all
that you get the leftist tears tumblr on
a day like this 105 degrees outside I
cannot wait for that camera to go off
I'm gonna fill this up with some nice
icy cold always salty and delicious
leftist tears and sit out by the pool it
is going to be absolutely fantastic and
if you can stick around and watch the
rest of the panel of deplorable --zz we
will teach you the seven tricks to have
a better life today to be the best you
so go over there right now
daily wire comm we'll be right back
[Music]
Hillary Clinton is hitting the road this
is the worst story this is worse than
the North Korean nuclear Clinton is
going on the road it's going to be a 15
City Hillary Clinton live tour you can
attend for a mere 1200 dollars per
ticket that's all that for a one low
price of 1200 ollars a ticket to see a
woman who just keeps losing the
presidency partes i hesitate to even ask
this tour is going through some states
that she lost last time around is she
seriously considering running a third
time what she's done it before I
wouldn't be surprised if she did it
again
running on helpless when you know that
you have you know you you've already
lost and continuing to run I don't see
any reason why she would stop she didn't
have a better answer I guess that's true
what is she gonna do now Kelly when will
it end when will Hillary Clinton finally
after I think 3,000 years of haunting
this earth when will she finally fade
away well I thought the name of her tour
Hillary Clinton live with rather an
oxymoron since we were all making fun of
her for looking like Hillary Clinton
Undead that's gonna be the name of the
tour it's the Walking Dead Season 5
starring Hillary Clinton who by the way
is Mike a little distant relative which
is just very disturbing hoping nobody
would bring that up I didn't want to
have to relive that trauma but Hillary
Clinton is I believe my second cousin
once removed a damn shame but I think
that Hillary just doesn't understand
that it's time to quit I mean obviously
I think she should have quit after the
2008 run or you know certainly after the
incredible Smackdown in 2012
you should think okay I'm really
unpopular I should just fade away be a
grandma it's time to be done but when
you have somebody who has spent her
entire life and devoted her entire life
to one thing and that's running for
president
it's probably just impossible for her to
let that go she doesn't know how to do
anything else other than you know maybe
earned we're
Qwest money and run for office and what
else is she going to do I have this
image of her at her kitchen sink with a
brillo pad like out damn spot you know
and she's just rubbing it for years and
years she says okay I got to do
something else I got to go on the road
or something partes Hillary Clinton in
this tour I have to quote this she
promises to let loose and tell her
audience a personal raw detailed and
surprisingly funny story of her election
loss nobody buys her books her own party
hates her who is going to show up for
this thing I mean okay on to someone who
won the presidency President Trump has
warned that all options are on the table
with regard to North Korea after they
launched a missile that fired over Japan
on Tuesday now this is the fourth
missile that North Korea has fired in
four days Kelly I thought we took care
of this what is the endgame here for
North Korea that's an excellent question
and I'm not really sure what I mean I
think that North Korea is basically
trying to you know put show that it has
muscle or whatever but I think in my
first instinct with North Korea has
always been to bomb them and you know
pick up the pieces later but that's why
I'm not president so I know the people
of Seoul are very happy but I think
Trump needs to respond with a very
measured response you know in the past
and this is why I've actually supported
president Trump's foreign policy largely
in the past we've had President Obama
you know come up with a red line and
then Russia or Syria or whatever will
cross the red line okay we're drawing a
new red line now you know part of sorry
go ahead
it seems like they've already been doing
that it's just hasn't been reported yet
and even I think it was earlier today on
Fox and Friends
Gorka who had just resigned he he had
kind of hinted that that's that's what
the Trump administration was already
doing that the US has already been
interfering in North Korea's missile
tests but I mean this was something that
was that was confidential and it wasn't
it's it hasn't been reported in the
media for obvious reasons and they I
mean it might that's it's not a
financial anymore
I think Fox & Friends is the it is a
morning briefing for the president but I
don't know if it's the classified one
yeah now on a much more important story
a much more relevant story to all of our
lives Coffee is apparently good for your
health the European Society of
Cardiology is reporting that
participants who consumed at least four
cups of coffee per day in a fairly broad
study had a 64 percent lower risk of
all-cause mortality than those who
almost never consumed coffee now part us
we already know that CAF FA is good for
your health is coffee also healthy and
is this just evidence the scientists
have no idea what they're talking about
because one day they tell us one thing
and the next day they tell us completely
the opposite I know what I'm talking
about because I've been drinking a
coffee for a long time now and so I
secretly knew that coffee I started
drinking coffee when I was six years old
and I think I'd probably be like six
foot four if I hadn't you know but I
don't regret it one bit I have no
regrets every one of those delicious
double lattes
I cherish in my memory Kelly is there a
strain of anti-science on the right
you know we joke about these guys don't
know what they're talking about and
it'll be the opposite tomorrow but is
there something about the right that
does question these scientists and if so
is it justified I think definitely just
because one minute it's it's butter and
that's bad no now it's margarine no no
it's butter again that's why at all I
tried to keep a balanced diet of butter
margarine and ice
I'll just spray Pam directly into my
mouth but it's you know it's cholesterol
it's it's gluten Oh and what's it gonna
be in ten years I do think that there is
a tendency because the right has been
tricked or misled so many times that
even when the left is correct on some
sort of scientific study the right is
just automatically going to question it
because so many times you've had as I
said you know it's butter it's margarine
I can't believe it's not butter I mean
all the rest of it you know it's um it's
almost like a bait and switch oh and so
the science gets politicized I mean that
the real point is I can't believe it's
not science when we talk about global
warming when we talk about different
areas of of health science very often
it's politicians who are pushing this
let's not forget it wasn't a scientist
who made the movie An Inconvenient Truth
it was a failed presidential candidate
so it mean is is that the issue is there
any way to deep politicize scientific
research or are they always going to
have policy recommendations and that's
always going to be political that's
actually something I haven't really
thought about I don't it's very once you
politicize something I I can't think of
a single example of deep politicizing it
right it would if we could take the I
think it it comes down to a money issue
if you take away the federal grants and
require that they all be private and
you're still gonna have whatever agenda
is behind the private money but at least
it's not tied to the government in any
way you don't have politicians
necessarily pushing it unless they're
part of the private organization so the
only thing I can suggest off the top of
my head is privatization but yeah it's
very hard to deal if that's your answer
for everything Calley privatized
privatized that's my answer to okay we
are running late and I'm melting so I
got to get out of this studio panel
thank you so much for being here
part of sale and Kelly companion now it
is time for me to put on my smart
glasses and mop the sweat off my brow
and read the final thought
if prosperity preachers like Joel Osteen
encourage you to do better for yourself
there doesn't seem to me anything
particularly wrong with that within that
narrow scope that Osteen sets for
himself
perhaps his message can encourage people
if so go with God the worry is that
people might take him for something that
he himself admits that he's not in the
weight of glory CS Lewis describes
heresy not as the promotion of Vice over
virtue but rather as the promotion of
some particular virtue over all the
others charity to the exclusion of
prudence justice to the exclusion of
charity the power of positive thinking
is neither a theological nor a cardinal
virtue and it shouldn't be confused for
one lest another Lewis admonition creep
up on you he warns if you look for truth
you may find comfort in the end if you
look for comfort you will not get either
comfort or truth only soft soap and
wishful thinking to begin and in the end
despair on that despairing note I am
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow and we'll give
you hope
[Music]
you
[Music]